what's up everybody welcome back to
gamespot cross kind of funny i'm your
host Greg Miller alongside Telltale
Games is high OBE Stauffer I don't have
to go thank you what oh pretty boss
preciate now Joe Greg I don't think the
internet understands how mind-bending
this is what what is this I've known you
a long time we have known each other for
a very long and every time I bring
somebody out to talk about telltale
games when I use to talk to you about
rockstar games yes many years you never
you never went on camera you never did
this you always stayed behind and you
finesse out these people you'd bring me
the voice actor of Omid and you'd sing
talk who is right over there that's why
I see him a shot at still alive loving
him uh but no now you're you've moved
into this role at telltale apparently
where you can go on camera and talk
about things yeah it's pretty much the
role of if Kevin Bruner has to go back
to the office and work on minecraft I'll
stay behind and talk to Greg Miller I'm
glad I'm glad I relationships Gladys
graduated to thee let's just not pretend
that the pr i-- isn't here we're
facebook official we're the relationship
between us is now public it is you can
update it so we're gonna talk all about
all the things going on at telltale yes
but when you took the job a telltale to
come in and be PR guy right here hack
whatever Liz know what it was that was
something like that yeah did you expect
it to evolve to this point um not in my
I mean not necessarily um I I had a
really good feelings about it it's and
again this isn't really about me but
like I make you a segment about you it's
all about you we're gonna cut to a clip
show or something gonna have a picture
um no I i personally started in early
2012 but before walking dead kind of
premiered and i'm working a games for a
long time I've known you for a long time
I've always loved telltale like as soon
as they air to the business now 11 years
ago with their first first car game
poker game texas holdem the texas
hold'em game you really good at your job
you know that's not this company and not
the greatest game ever but it was their
first game they hit off a bone than
salmon max yeah huge fan for a long time
and I've just oh I always really you
know believed in what else I was doing
going digital going episodic doings
doing making games that are more like
television yeah and really building
something for an audience that like me
was just kind of getting older like
yourself getting older I'm an ancient
now and and you know you kind of you're
always kind of looking for this
experience that you can kind of consume
in a more timely fashion yeah and really
give yourself something where I always
say like this it's like I just want
something that I can start to play after
dinner and finish before bed right and
then talk about it the next day because
like I we all love games I love games
the entire team we all play all the big
stuff battlefront call of duty we play
everything yeah we're excited for all
the new stuff coming out this year is
freaking crazy by the way 63 degrees
everywhere you turn as an amazing game
right there it's it's absolutely nuts
but like we you know we're all core
gamers we all play a ton of stuff but
more gamers core or well I don't know
what else would you call it someone
already core game somebody's gonna play
by play mobile games you get the [ __ ]
out of here now anyway how all your
games mobile by the way hey yes sorry
about that um but no like way I've
always wanted something that you know
was kind of growing with with with sort
of where i saw the industry's going sure
kind of colliding with television and
film and tell tell is just you know as
it was growing into that and i think
walking dead was certainly pivotal for
the company you're right um and you know
it's just been a wild ride you know
since since day one and it's just it's
just going and going and everyone's just
working super super hard the team is
growing we actually have a recruiting
team here talking to people and bring it
on some great talent we're hiring all
the time ballpark how big is the team
right now because talk about 300 okay
yeah is that enough to even come close
to doing all you do um it I mean it is
right now yeah give me what you have
Game of Thrones cooking you walking dead
cooking you announce this Michonne
spin-off cooking walkie dead michonne a
telephone games miniseries I don't
need it all that we knew we were talking
about all right you got minecraft
minecraft story you got a Marvel thing
happening now then you're also doing an
original game you were finally talking
about you're getting on that path yeah
so that's six things going right there
what did I forget I'm sure lots of
things that we haven't announced yet you
forgot what other properties are you
working what are you doing more Skybound
stuff invincible tell me it's invincible
does that conflicted marvel then don't
then leave don't do invincible do
outcast look at the time you know
that'll any a good thing Sparkman does
that you could do uh I think he's got
lots of cool stuff uh we love working
with him and hey we're having a panel
with Robert what's san diego comic-con
oh and who's moderating that i don't
know i didn't put that together please
put me it's me it should be me is what I
was thinking Tammy should it be me tim
says it should be me all right um oh
here comes Tim left is a war here now
let's look at this act let's for a
second talk on Sundays good job good a
good job inserting yourself in a proper
time cuz that was good I'm that was good
um so here's what I need you to do yes
you know that I'm the biggest Walking
Dead fan in the industry I think I've
heard that I have been going full steam
ahead on this e to be kind of funny
business uh-huh I know nothing about
this Michonne miniseries good people
announced hey on my Twitter somebody's
like talk about them as shown miniseries
they said this Sunday night and I was
like okay I I thought it was an AMC
thing right then today I was like tell
tales on there like asking my I'm like
oh it's a game right what is happening
with this machine oh I'm sorry what is
happening with Telltale Games is the
walking dead the Michonne mini series
featuring Kevin Bruner ah it's a
three-part miniseries okay just
announced thankfully you know I think
there were a lot of big surprises at e3
some work too surprising a lot of the
stuff got out thankfully we kept that a
secret until monday morning but yes so
later this fall three part series it
stars Michonne you'll be playing as
Michonne remember we're working with
Robert Kirkman and sky bound it's all
based in the comic style universe
everybody so there's the comic continuum
and there's the AMC sort of version of
the universe we're on the comics ID so
this is the Michonne it doesn't matter
if you've read the comics
through you know issue 126 sure not it's
great if you did you should but there's
a point in time without spoiling too
much Michonne leaves she leaves the sort
of where the group is yeah she
disappears for quite some time there's
actually a time jump all the characters
move forward in time they come back and
eventually she comes back so where was
she what was she doing what did she go
through what drove her way and what
brought her back so just talking about
the Robert for a long time you know the
season want to walking dead probably had
I'd only had really kind of to clear
ties to the characters or the comic we
had Glen we saw person and we saw
Hershel inertials form beyond that we
kind of went around direction to kind of
told her own story something that hadn't
been touched in the comics there's no
point in telling Rick story again go
down the same Rick path especially with
our our style storytelling it's really
about telling the story you want to tell
ya so no needs a retread any the same
girl for the comics but we still have
always wanted to tie that universe
together a little more closely I know
Robert has we have and this sort of time
gap in the comics kind of just presented
this crazy opportunity with Michonne who
we love you know we've been thinking
about that amount of time she's kind of
perfect for a telltale role what here's
my question about it is like is it
perfectly and I'm putting you on the
spot here owning the bus i'm throwing
into the Wolves I'm gonna kill you I'm
gonna Victoria is it perfect because
like if we're filling in the gap of the
comic which is awesome by the way when
you said I thought I might even I
thought it was gonna be pre-cooled
everything that happened not filling in
a very vital story here that's a current
for the moment making the choices there
how does that then get put into the
comic later on like well um I got you
see threw him to the wolves everybody
Greg Miller best video game journalists
on the plane oh I will obviously spoil
alert she won't die in our store well
sure yeah I wasn't you gotta come back
into the count right but if you've been
reading the comic you know that it gets
pretty dark with her yeah she a lot of
stuff has happened to her you know
before the outbreak in the outbreak you
know she's lost her children and she's
pretty far gone in the comic and she has
a not terribly great run-in with
governor yeah
there's a spoon involved at one point
it's pretty tough yeah a lot of stuff
she's a deep character but sort of
discovering what's driving her away and
why she you know actually if you
noticing that key art that we released
some people were confused you know where
is that her katana where's your katana
her katana gets left behind that's
actually a machete so you understand
that gets left behind where she you
wouldn't screw that up immediately we
would not spit up being wanted to make
sure that didn't but see that's the
problem not all these cat is I column
casual Walking Dead fans they come here
and I like Oh Chandler Riggs is so cute
and that's all they know they don't know
it's adorable he isn't he's a dreamboat
um but why her well I would say is uh
it's the kind of thing we look for a
telltale Game it's really just a range
that they present as a character yeah um
if you look at Lee look at Clementine
you will get Nick Chester over there
from harmonix what up Nick yes sir got a
lot of range um he is a lot of range um
you know she's been through a lot she's
the kind of character you could be in a
situation where she can either you know
totally lash out or totally remain
silent any time she's got her rough sort
of demeanor to her she's she's kind of
that character where she's we call it a
swing character oh yeah people holy crap
everyone who's ever voicing a tomboy sad
is coming around to score a man oh wow
it's got Porter showing up at for you
too is he gay oh man Jesus um but no I
mean she's got the range shot the range
kind of like a big be kind of like
Clementine there's a lot that you can do
with her in an innocent area so now are
you mad that you've painted yourself
into the corner because we know in the
comics Michonne in Ezekiel there's
that's part of her story and we won't
get into anything of what that means but
obviously I started a campaign to get
Dave fennoy to play Ezekiel on the
walking dead TV show but now Dave fennoy
who started as Lee Everett in the
walking dead game can't come back
invoice Ezekiel in your new verte it's
the time it's time is broken well
fission mailed I think it might be a
little confusing to hear Lee's voice as
Ezekiel yeah if he shows up in the
miniseries not committing it anything
he's going to don't worry that's a Greg
Miller lock that's a lock of the wheeler
guarantee
um but no i mean it's it's really just
an opportunity yeah and it's you know
we're working on it now we're in the
middle of writing this thing we kind of
know where it's starting we know we're
descending we're wrapping up this first
episode it's going to be premiering this
fall that's the trickiest thing about
our projects is not spoiling the insurer
experience right how do you cut a
trailer for a game it's all about like
metal reactions that's also something we
run into here like shows like III where
you know we aren't showing anything here
you know we announced it but right now
we're just doing some private meetings
with some more announces to the next two
to three weeks yeah um but with a
telltale experience we have people that
we have lots of you if I want to see it
but then they also think okay well don't
show too much like I was I don't want to
see everything I think it was here a
couple years ago you should not
obviously a couple years ago where you
showed me episode two or three if that
was that that was 20 12 you started
playing those like oh no don't no wait
not gonna leave the room I don't want to
write about this uh it's it's it's a
really really tricky spot to be in but
we were here yeah uh I think there
there's always gonna be some cool
stopper news player games like packs
yeah I think packs will have a big
series okay hopefully if all's going
well um you're a big series to announce
ah maybe a big series where you might be
able to play for the first time oh maybe
a new franchise we'll see maybe I
minecraft noodles I don't know you don't
know you don't know what they have any
whatever happens out there happens so
that's the thing how do you keep all
these balls in the air how you keep all
the plates spinning like you have so
many projects going on um so we can ask
that along a lot about development yeah
um typically you know with a big
publisher a big developer you know you
have guys in you know Sweden the guys in
Vancouver or teams all over the world
working on different games for for a
core developer for core publisher with
us we're all sort of under one roof
we're all in san rafael in marin county
right near san francisco it's all kind
of like one big family yeah and you know
we're all creating different telltale
experiences you know if you pick up
walking dead or if you pick up you know
Game of Thrones or eventually when you
pick up minecraft you're going to
identify that as signature itself gotcha
but our team's kind of its I'd say this
but it's it's highly incestuous so we'll
have people that are obviously leading
projects yeah
but then we also have people that you
know are aware of what makes a great
telltale Game what makes a great
telltale episode that can sort of jump
between you know when you start looking
at the credits for your games when the
episodes are beginning use often see is
directed by and then all these learnings
and they all move around they do so when
you play Game of Thrones like oh I know
that person from tales from the
borderlands or this name makes sense
from the walking dead yeah it's um
Dennis Leonard all over this thing
Dennis one aren't all over actually got
um so tales from the borderlands uh he
got that going on the third episodes out
on tues we have Ashley rule shout out to
Ashley I think she's our first female
director of an episode hey look at that
so sheriff video games moving forward
super stoked for that episodes yeah ah
that's out on Tuesday it's it's what
took that one so long everybody losing
every minute cuz tales from the
borderlands I'll tell you what Walking
Dead you announced like help yes I'm on
board I love the walking dead fables you
announced oh my god I'm not gonna like
this one tales from the borderlands you
announce and I'm Mike how's that even
gonna work I like be exactly was that
but it was also like I like Borderlands
but not for the story but what's
happening and I sat down and I had one
of those things from I want to play a
game and I tried a million different
things none of it work and then I jumped
in and I played tales from Portland's
and I was like this is hilarious i can't
wait but then we did it we played you
know episode 2i we had lots of alcohol i
think there yeah we did a lot onto a TV
/ kind of funny lots of drink kind of
funny HQ yeah Laura was there we owe
barely Troy Baker showed up ah that's a
while might we'll do that again good
okay good what do you have to set three
yeah right so next week just you gotta
mail him up or whatever no good people
chance play but that one took a little
longer didn't if he were waiting for
they were no longer because look we want
to put out episodes as quickly as you
can and service the fans and everyone
who's you know by mrs. Bass's but at the
end of the day you know we want the
episode to be great and you know we
listen to the Great's when they say you
know a bad game is bad forever right so
when it's good when we think that you
guys will love it will ship it is it one
of those things though since you are
incestuously you're moving people around
does it become a domino effect of if
this one game takes you long and it
knocks back walking down and expects
Michaux no not necessarily i think we've
scaled up to the point where we have
that balance and that everything sort of
moving their own trajectory but it's
really just a matter of when is it good
and when do we
love it when do we think you're gonna
love it great so but you'll be loving
that one I hope fingers crossed on
Tuesday you can't screw it up I hope not
with that we don't take anything for
granted but we just we won't entertain
we want people to just have an awesome
telltale experience so then jump me back
to Michonne sure that's pressing yes
interesting to Greg Miller the rest of
the stuff you said it was garbage
uniting terra firma shown heard nothing
wow I'm just been on uh-huh uh-huh no
machete uh-huh no uh why do this instead
of getting started on season three of
The Walking Dead I think season three is
still a long ways off yeah I think
there's some more that we're kind of
working on and figuring out and I think
season three is going to be considerably
perhaps larger and more significant
undertaking for the open world oculus
game you heard of here first um but you
know it walking dead is you know it
working the sky on a Robert there just a
premier partner for us and it's just
huge to work with them and when we do
the third season we want it to be big we
want it to be incredible we've said
nothing about it yeah noticed we don't
even know who your Li playing as we have
noticed how it'll be tying together to
season two more than Michonne series
it's a ways off ok I think the first
time you'll hear more about it like with
any substance will be after the Michelle
Renee series concludes ok so a long time
okay well you know later okay we've long
as relative and telltale time it's kind
of like working in dog years yeah like
you know we have you know we're working
so for us like you know next year maybe
you could hear something yeah that's you
look you'll get like you know the big
studios like you know dice and rock star
and it's like years and years and years
we hear the next thing ya with us it's
kind of like you know you got to kind of
look at the programming schedule well I
can see exactly you guys are a
networking spinning somebody played so
it's like I'm waiting for the walking
dead news but then you give me the
minecraft news you'll give me
Borderlands news you do all this stuff
you'll put out another Walking Dead game
it's a reni sense so now here's my
question that I want I want I want a
response from you sure uh
people on the internet we're clear of
them will give it to tell tale once
while but give you the jabs how so that
well for long cuz I've never noticed for
a long time it was you know well their
engine doesn't run well on this and then
you just you did the smart thing and you
waited out the ps3 and 360 so they're
gone no but nobody has to worry about
him now yours we're still servicing them
then you any other question on PS you
can answer girl then get ready for more
common ok not running well but the
question more I think is that you seen
scale-up recently this actually comes
from one Colin Moriarty every so often
is that he he keeps saying he'd like to
see you guys take a break and come back
with something completely different like
right in my argument to him always and I
maybe I was answering my own question
because I do that sometimes my argument
is that I think the way you guys are
programming what you're doing is you are
building a TV network and so yeah
mechanically Game of Thrones Walking
Dead Borderlands are very similar if not
the same right but it's a rare breed of
somebody who plays all of them sure is
that what is that how you guys dress it
or do you think this is a fair complaint
or no I think for for what we're doing
what like building this sort of
interactive storytelling Network kind of
way you know like a premium channel for
gamers for players and even though it's
familiar when you go from Game of
Thrones still walking dead the thing is
is that we're a multi-genre studio just
like you know an HBO on AMC they're
telling different stories you consume
that content you consume those shows my
sitting down in front of a TV and
watching it yeah when you're playing a
telltale experience you're making
decisions you're driving the story we're
inventing new ways to sort of handle the
mechanics scene to scene but ideally
it's going to feel familiar we want you
to know to kind of what to expect on how
to play it we don't want that bear you
to be super high we want you to be able
to enjoy it just as much as you know
maybe your mom or my mom my mom plays
Game of Thrones she's six I won't say
her age she's old little she's she's not
old she's young at heart everybody young
at heart but like she's a huge game of
thrones fan read all the books watch the
show yeah and she plays on her iPad and
that's the thing is like we want the
same experience that's on console or on
PC just be the same thing that's on your
tablet and on your
so having that sort of intuitive control
of the narrative is really the goal
we're six thousand different devices
yeah iOS Android amazon everything
PlayStation it's is the same experience
and that's really what we're building
towards where even though it's
mechanically very familiar the stories
are different sure I mean borderlands is
a completely dif the ponies game even a
sci-fi action comedy we've got
apocalyptic zombie drama with Walking
Dead game of thrones it's all different
you know the stories are different just
like TV it's not like you know it moved
to gym or genres it's like watching a
different show sure makes sense i'm with
you i think i think colin colin is not
calling sighs nope collins great for the
record hey what are you gonna do now
tough guy bridling island eat your
mayonnaise fries over there piece of
work so then now how long had you guys
been working on landing Marvel poof um I
know you're not gonna tell me anything
about the games of the characters or any
more I mean it's you know it's it's kind
of works both ways yeah um there's a lot
of opportunity right now for us and
we're we're very kind of selective on
who we can work with and we really want
to yeah Marvel was right at the top of
our list sure that's a tricky thing too
is you know that's we an outside as
we're doing a project you're going to
see in 2017 it's now 2015 we've got a
lotta ground a cover before we get to
2017 you'll see more series premiering
and more projects sort of landing long
before the Marvel project actually sort
of comes out of hiding and sure what it
is you know working on I'm not gonna
play into your games till back okay good
just I just want to be fresh when I go I
want that fresh experience I want to
know okay it's been a while you know
it's um that you know it's a there a
dream partner to work with yeah um it's
amazing to know what we're gonna be
doing so you know oh yeah give me it's
you know it's based on comic comic
franchise okay and we think you'll
that's what's so fascinating about it is
like you know you've known me again for
years and every time we're together
aight i would tell you to either get
Robert let you make invincible or
convince DC to let you do Superman
because everybody always [ __ ] that
there can't be a good Superman game and
I disagree and I'm ready and waiting
Warner Brothers DC for you to toss me a
money in a budget and teach me how to
make games but more importantly the fact
that like these powerful characters that
we play as and then you run into these
walls of like well I can't fly to the
moon and Olaf wants to throw it like by
putting it into the tell-tale story
structure right all of a sudden it
becomes the actions playing out and yeah
it's changing is if I don't hit this
button prompt you know I I would remind
you still have not played the wolf among
us have you I started to and then I
didn't like it you didn't like it now
how far you get I got midway through not
even midway I got to the first part of
episode to it you know you know who
liked it everyone else in the whole wide
world everyone else every time I talk
about not like we can actually cannot
honestly every single day I get emails
where's the wolf among us season two I
got physical letters in the mail yeah
you know handwritten from people hey
guys is all great where's the fungus
season that was your mom it was it was
not my mama's fun um she's anyway it's
as an example of yes taking a comic
character who has powers rises ability
to sort of just take over seeing at any
time when you give you know the player
the role-playing opportunity of in an
actual dramatic situation what are you
going to do how are you going to behave
that's kind of like what you were kind
of asking for yeah I think we kind of
covered that and I think a lot of what
you've seen in wolf will certainly
parlay into what you might see next if
the next property based on a comic
should cover anyone that has great
powers or are just normal people just
like on do you think you're what back
you just brought up wolf everybody's
writing these letters is there a chance
at another wolf ever I think we were all
super super kind of surprised by the
reaction of that says we had you know
that was the first series were
premiering right after the end of season
one walking dead season two's first
episode was like a month and a half
after that yeah so pressure was on you
know I remember being at e3 2013 and
just wondering oh man are we gonna be
able to show this thing yeah is it right
and just we trev and we're Evan rear
Evan we just try really hard to try and
get something that hopefully anyone will
enjoy or or hopefully is you know like
and want to play and
so it's possible well you're not gonna
commit to anything as usual I think I
think we're committed to quite a lot
anymore yeah you are Joe uh but that's
exciting and I think we definitely hear
people calling for it um nothing we can
say right nothing at this time we'll job
at this time i love you i love telltale
games thank you i love shown this fall
you said Michonne three-part miniseries
premiering this fall which you'll be
able to download if you all you need is
the first episode of season two Owen
it's free uh no I mean we oh I see
you're saying I seriously download it
into see it's feel season to season two
okay it's not really all of our stuff is
dlc yeah downloadable alright so we have
to FC episode wanna do whatever whenever
would you what's real I phone anyway all
right fine Jo sang grow home and make
more marvel game we will make lots of
games all right I'll talk to you soon
for having us everybody this is gamespot
cross finding got demon I said I screwed
up my part I was so worried about
screwing up gamespot this is gamespot
cross kind of funny and we'll be back
with more after this